[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Hello, everybody.
I'm Francesc Campoy,
and today I'm
going to be talking
about Cloud Endpoints.
The whole point of the
talk is to give you
an idea of what Google Cloud
Endpoints is able to do today
and to also give you a--
let you imagine what we
will be adding later on.
A little bit about myself, I'm
a Developer Advocate at Google.
So my job is to advocate for
developers and make them happy.
I've been working with the
Go Team for quite a while.
And I care mostly about
developer experience.
That is basically my whole goal.
To have developers
that are happy
means that their
experience should be good.
And that's why I'm so excited
about Google Cloud Endpoints.
Because it makes
developer experience
for many things actually nice,
which is not something that--
it's not always
the word that you
can use when you're talking
about Auth2 and stuff
like that.
So the agenda for today
is going to be-- we're
going to start talking first
about what is actually an API,
and specifically, a REST
API, which is part of what
Cloud Endpoints can do for you.
Then we're going to talk about,
how do you document an API?
An API is many things.
But it's specifically
something that
helps you use someone
else's services.
You need to tell them what
they can do with your service.
How do you do that?
We're going to be
talking about that.
And then we're going to
talk about Cloud Endpoints.
We're going to talk about
what you can do with it.
What is the
developer experience?
But also about how it's actually
architectured behind it so
you can understand exactly
how it works and understand
how you could extend it.
And finally, we're going to
do what the talk is about,
serving your API to the world.
And the world will be myself,
in this case, but you know,
it's something.
So let's start with,
what is an API?
I'm sure that you all
know what an API is.
You've all used at
least once an API.
And API's an Application
Programming Interface.
And basically,
the whole point is
that it allows other
programs use your programs.
An API is not for
people to use it.
It's for machines.
That's pretty much it.
So you could have a web page.
We have a webpage serving
some data from a data store.
And you can either
use the webpage--
you're a human being and you
go in there click on buttons.
But if you're a
program, you don't
want to go there
clicking buttons,
because then you
need to scrape HTML.
And if you've ever done
that, it's not super fun
and also not always allowed.
So very often we
allow this other way
of using the program,
same program,
just a different
way of using it.
Cool, so what is a REST API?
I'm not going to try to
remember what REST stands for,
because there's no
point and it really
doesn't mean that much,
at least in my opinion.
But REST is about
these three things.
We have resources.
And those resources
are your things,
the things that you care
about on your business logic.
So for instance, you could
think about accounts, products--
I was going to say sales,
but that is not the word.
Whatever.
You can find many different
things, products, accounts,
or whatever.
That is the main example.
Then you have the methods, which
is what you can do with those.
So you could create
a new customer.
You could delete it.
You could update a customer.
You could do many of the
things that you can do.
And the whole point
is that in a REST API
those actions that you
can do are actually
tied to well-understood
HTTP methods.
Right?
So you have POST.
When you do POST, normally
you create a new one.
When you do PUT, you give
a key, you update it.
GET is to get stuff,
as it says, et cetera.
And finally we have
the representation.
And representation, in
the case of rest the APIs,
is normally JSON.
So for example, we can have here
our /product that represents
our resource, so all the
products that we have.
If we do a POST and send this
JSON here, what we're doing
is we're creating a new
resource with that POST method,
pretty simple.
Now, this is REST, right?
This is not REST.
This is gRPC.
But with gRPC you
can actually do
things that are very,
very, very similar to REST.
You can create REST, not
RESTful, but RESTish--
I decided to call them--
RESTish APIs that basically
allow you to do the same things
with the same style but
with a different way
of naming the resources.
Normally, in this case, it
could be product service.
You can create them
calling it, create method.
And the representation,
rather than being JSON,
is protocol buffers.
How many of you have used
protocol buffers before?
OK.
So just a quick description
of protocol buffers,
protocol buffers is the
way we do everything
at Google, basically.
Many of the teams at Google,
we say that what we do
is we decode protocol
buffers, and then
we code them again
somewhere else.
That's pretty much what
you do most of the time.
They're basically like JSON,
but when you encode them
they're encoded
as binary format.
Then coding and decoding
is way faster and also
more performance when
you want to send it.
At the same time, they
are better for versioning.
So if you have never
used protocol buffers
I think it's a good thing to do.
But today we're
going to be talking
about REST APIs-- so JSON.
Cool.
So let's talk about
the demo that we're
going to be using today.
We're going to be using
one of the simplest
demos, because the
whole point of the demo
is not to have a very
complicated, very
complicated domain.
It's to show you all the
things that Cloud Endpoints can
do for you without having
to add, basically, any code.
OK.
So let me see-- there you go.
I had to restart
my computer right
before coming on stage,
which is never a good idea.
OK.
So I have my
Container Engine here.
I have my container cluster.
You can see my container cluster
has three nodes running there.
And if I go here and I do
kubectl, or kube, C-T-L proxy,
I can access this 8001, UI.
And we should be able to
see that I have a service
right here.
And that service is
running my service.
I'm running it on
Container Engine.
You could be running
on App Engine.
You could be running anywhere.
You could be running
on on-premise.
That's totally fine.
Cloud Endpoints
works on any platform
that you might want to use.
So I can get that URL.
Open postman.
Those are gophers
because I write Go.
[CHUCKLES]
Postman, there you go.
So I can now send
a request there.
OK.
So if I'm able to do a
copy/paste correctly.
There you go, Body.
OK.
So if I send--
what is going on?
Raw.
There you go.
OK.
So I can send some JSON and
say, my message is hello.
And then I can send it.
And I receive it back.
That's it.
That's everything
this demo does.
You send a message, and it
receives this back, right?
Right now there's no
Cloud Endpoints going on.
It's just some Containers
running on Kubernetes, GKE,
Google Container Engine.
That's pretty much it.
Now what we're going
to do, of course,
is to actually add
Cloud Endpoints to this
and see everything we can do.
If I remember
correctly-- there you
go-- if you write something
that doesn't correspond,
it's not good
JSON, it will fail.
And also, if you try
to send something
to a URL that doesn't
exist, you will get a 404.
If you get a 404 that
is kind of an ugly one,
it's just some text.
So if you're
serving an API, this
is probably not
what you want to do.
But we'll see how Endpoints
actually fixes that directly
without you having
to do anything.
Demoing with two computers
at the same time is not easy.
[CHUCKLES]
OK.
So we have that demo, right?
And the next question is, well,
I want to let people use it,
to use it, right?
How can they use it?
What is the message
they should send?
they should receive?
What are the paths
that are accepted?
What are the methods on those
paths that are accepted?
Right?
And you could do many things.
You could just tell them.
You can go and talk to every
single one of the developers
and tell them, oh,
yeah, it's /echo.
And it needs to be POST.
It needs to send JSON
that has message--
but message needs to be
lowercase, by the way,
just in case you forget.
It's something
that you could do,
but I don't recommend
that, especially if you're
serving this to the world.
So what do we do instead?
Well, we could show the code.
And in this case, I could
say, right, I'm telling you.
I've showed you the code.
So you can see this code.
If you know how to write some
Go code, you'll be like, OK,
so there it is right there.
If you send a POST
method to echo,
then the echoHandler
function is cool.
So then I could
follow up and try
to understand what we're
trying to decode, what are we
trying to encode?
Not perfect, but this
is a little bit better
than just telling people.
Or you could go contract first.
And by contract first
what I'm saying is,
rather than writing the
code and telling people
about it, what I'm going
to do is I'm actually
going to agree with people.
This is my API.
This is how it's
going to be used.
And from there, I'm going
to start writing my code.
And now this has a
bunch of benefits.
One of the benefits it has is
that it improves collaboration
across teams or across projects.
If I clarify my API
clearly, afterwards I
could change completely the
way I'm implementing behind.
I could move from App
Engine to Compute Engine.
I could do whatever I want.
If I don't break that
API, I should not
be impacting any of the teams
that are using my service.
So that is pretty important.
But also, there is
many other ones.
And what are you
looking for when
you're talking about the
way you document APIs?
Right?
Like, we're saying,
if you specify
very well what you can do
with an API, then you're good.
You get all these advantages.
Well, the first
thing you need to do
is you need to be very accurate.
You need to specifically
say all the things
that you need to do to use my
service, which means that also
you need to be very expressive.
Because imagine that if
the language that you're
trying to use to express all
the things about your API
doesn't allow you to
say, oh, by the way,
the JSON object
should look like this.
And finally, it
needs to be readable.
And when I say readable, there's
actually two readables here.
There's readable by humans
and readable by machines.
Right?
I want something
that I, as a person,
can go, and read, and understand
correctly, and have a very good
idea of how to use this API.
But also, as a
software engineer--
which is a kind
of person maybe--
what I want to do
is I want to parse
that description of the API so I
can build stuff on top of that.
So free text, is it accurate?
No.
Free text feels accurate
but is way too artsy.
You can write many things
in many different ways that
might be ambiguous,
especially if you're not
a native English
speaker, like me.
There's things that
you could write
that actually means
something slightly different
depending on the context.
So free text, not the best.
But expressiveness,
it's amazing.
You can express
everything in the world
with free text, so, of course.
And readability, it is awesome
for humans, awful for machines.
We're working on that
with machine learning.
But I would not
recommend using machine
learning to parse
recommendation for APIs
to create all the tools.
That-- it's cool, as a demo.
But I don't think
it's a very good idea.
So let's go down the other side.
It's incredibly accurate.
It says exactly what
you want to say.
There's no ambiguity.
It is very expressive,
because you're actually
writing the whole domain.
Very often the
source code does--
expresses way more
than just your API.
It expresses exactly
all the process.
But readability-wise, I'd say
that even though for machines
it's pretty easy to read--
I mean, it depends on
the prominent language,
but most of the
prominent languages
are done to be parsed.
Breathability for human
beings is not that good.
Because first, you need to
talk to someone that programs
and in your
programming language.
I program in Go.
If you're a programmer that
has never written in Go
and only knows--
I don't know,
let's say, Haskell.
From Haskell to Go,
there's a big difference.
If you need to understand
Go to be able to use my API,
that's not a good thing.
And then finally we
have design languages.
And those design languages,
there's many of them.
But the design
language is-- basically
the idea is that you create
a new language in between.
Right?
That language, the
whole idea is that it's
accurate and
expressive enough to be
able to describe your API
without ambiguity but not
completely.
You're not going to be able
to express the whole thing
that your API might
do in all the corner
cases with design language.
It's not a programming language.
But on the other hand,
it's more readable.
It is more readable, in
general, for human beings.
And it's definitely more
readable for machines.
That is the whole point.
You're building something
that is very possible.
So it feels like we should
go with the one that
has the better tradeoffs.
So I'd go with the last one.
Which one?
Well, you could go with RAML.
You could go with WSDL--
I think it's pronounced.
You can go with WADL, or WADL,
depending on where you're from.
Or you can go with OPEN API
Initiative also previously
known as Swagger.
How many of you
have used Swagger?
Cool.
OK.
So that is the one we're using.
If you use Swagger,
the whole point
is that you're able to
do many cool things.
You specify mainly
for components.
So when you're
doing a Swagger API,
you have information
about the API itself.
It's basically documentation.
You have paths.
So what are the paths in
the URL that you're serving?
What are the operations in them?
What are the methods for
every single one of the paths?
And then for input
and output, you're
basically defining
those messages.
Those messages are what
we call definitions.
And finally, there are
security definitions.
So basically, what you're going
to have is for information,
in this case, we have
description, "A Google Cloud
Endpoints API example," a
title, a version, a host--
which is, where should
I go to find this API?
And then you're going to have
also, what are you receiving?
What are you sending?
So in this case,
application JSON.
We're receiving JSON,
sending back JSON.
And we're serving
everything on HTTPS.
All of this doesn't
say anything about what
you can do with the API.
This is just like
the documentation
for humans to read and a
little bit of where to find it.
I went too fast with that one.
Then we have the paths.
And in paths, for instance, in
this case you could say, well,
if you go to /echo and
you send a request,
which is a POST method, then
you have this operation.
OK?
That operation, what
you're doing is saying,
well, there's the description.
This is the operationID.
And we're going to see
what this is useful for.
OperationID is not compulsory,
but it's very useful
when you're generating code.
And you'll again say what it's
producing, application JSON.
And then you have
responses and parameters.
And this is very interesting,
because basically
what you're saying is-- what
do I get from the request?
So what are the parameters
that I'm receiving?
And what do I send back?
In our case, the responses
we're going to say,
well, there's two cases.
One is 200, also known
as the status code, OK.
And in which case, we're
sending the echo back.
Our [AUDIO OUT] says.
It just sends the message back.
So that's what it does.
And it sends something
with schema, echoMessage.
And that is actually a
reference to a definition
that we're going
to see in a minute.
So basically you're saying,
what are you going to send?
But in other cases,
default, we're
going to be sending
an error message.
And the error message
is also well-defined.
So we're saying it's
an error message, which
is also in definitions.
What do we receive?
Well, that you're going
to have in parameters.
And we're going to say that
we're receiving a message.
So the schema is
again the echoMessage.
But what is interesting
is we are actually saying
these will be in the body.
Right?
You could have many
different places.
You could have this as
a parameter in the URL.
You could have it
as part of the path.
There is many places where
that information could be.
And Swagger, Open
API specification
allows you to specify exactly
where this is coming from.
What does the
definition look like?
Well, error message.
We're saying, for instance,
this is a type: object.
So it has a bunch of fields.
And the fields are both
required, messaging code,
and messages of type: string.
Code is an integer.
And you can even say
it's from 100 to 600,
because that's what
HTTP codes are for.
Cool.
So what do I get from this?
Actually, a bunch of stuff.
You get really cool things.
So you can create
documentation from this that
is very readable for humans.
You can create code.
And you can even create
developer portals,
which is very useful.
If you've ever used
any Google API, for me,
one of the coolest things
we have is the Google--
the API playground,
the API Explorer.
Where you can go,
search your APIs,
go send the message
directly without having
to install anything.
So you understand the API before
you start writing any code.
So let's demo that.
OK.
So what I'm going to
do first is make sure
that my server is
running locally.
Not that one but this one here.
OK.
There it is.
I should get
something complaining.
There you go.
OK.
So my server is now running.
And what I can do is
I can visit editor--
wrong window-- editor,
Swagger editor.
Wrong window.
I have too many windows.
There you go, this one.
And with this one,
what I'm doing
is basically I just copied
that Swagger definition
onto this editor.
This editor is something
that is very simple.
It's online.
You don't need to
install anything.
Now the cool thing
about this is that we
can see on the right side
this documentation, where
you can see if you
send POST to echo,
the description, you
have all the parameters,
you can understand quite
easily how to use it.
The more documentation you
add in the specification file,
you get a documentation
that is easier
to use for your developers.
And then on top of that,
you can try an operation.
You can say exactly
what you're going to be
sending, what you're receiving.
It is able to tell
you-- actually,
the echoMessage object has
a field, which is required,
message, and you then send it.
So it's able to do
validation for yourself.
It's able to do this
validation even in a proxy
that you don't need to write
yourself, which is pretty cool.
So you can write, hello, Google
Cloud Next, send it there.
And we get a response with
a message coming back.
And we can see what
it looks exactly.
And if you think
about this, if you're
offering these tools
to the developers that
are trying to use
your API, this is
way more useful than
amazing documentation.
In my opinion, documentation
is great to read it,
but when I want to use
your API, I want this.
I want to be able to find
what operation is doing what
and what are the
exact fields that I
need to send, try
it, and then write
my code that will do the same.
There's an important thing if
you try to do this at home.
There is the fact that there is
what is called the Cross-Origin
HTTP request.
I don't know if you heard
about this, CORS, C-O-R-S.
The whole point is security.
If you try to do this
onto a server that is not
running locally,
you start to need
to take care of these things.
There's documentation
about that.
I feel like every single person
that has tried to use this tool
has discovered the
options method.
It's a method in
HTTP that nobody
uses except for this tool.
So you need to support it.
Cool.
OK.
So this brings a
lot of value, right?
But again, this is still
not Cloud Endpoints.
What is Cloud Endpoints?
Well, Cloud Endpoints
is something
that has been built to--
given just this specification--
give you more value, give
you a bunch of things
that you need to do.
If you want to expose
your API to the world,
there's things like
monitoring authentication
that you should be doing.
But you do not need
to write those.
So that is exactly what
Cloud Endpoints does.
Let's see that.
Whoops.
OK.
So if you've used Cloud--
has anyone used Cloud Endpoints
previously, like one year ago?
OK.
So these may be familiar to you.
Cloud Endpoints is
a framework that
runs on App Engine
standard environment,
either for Java or
Python, and that's it.
No.
Not anymore.
That's the whole point
of Cloud Endpoints
is getting that idea that
people loved and make
it accessible to everywhere--
no matter if you're
running Java, Python,
or Go, or PHP,
or whatever language you want.
And if you're running it on
APP Engine, or in a Container,
or somewhere in a machine
that is hiding in your closet.
We do not care about that.
You are able to run it wherever.
So what it is is an API
gateway, and it's an API gateway
that is distributed.
We're going to see that later
on the architecture diagrams.
But the cool thing is that
this is very integrated, right?
So it is integrated with
deployments for App Engine.
If you're using App Engine
flexible environment,
it's a great experience.
It is simply-- you are just--
one little field in
your app in the demo.
You redeploy and that's it.
You're done, which is amazing.
But for Container
Engine it is-- which
is what we're going to be
doing-- it's very easy.
And if you want to do
anything else, it is doable.
It might be a little
bit harder to implement,
but it is definitely doable.
And it also integrates
with Stackdriver logging
and Stackdriver Trace.
So whenever you
receive a request,
you're going to be able
to see that in your logs
and also in traces.
So you're going to be able
to track, to measure latency,
and things like
that, without having
to carry it in your code.
So the key features
are authentication.
So you're able to authenticate
users and control who
has access to what.
All of this, just
by adding things,
security definitions to
your open API specification.
You're going to get also
logging and monitoring.
And this is really fast.
It is incredibly fast.
And it scales really well.
And we're going
to see why it's--
I'm not a marketing
person, so I'm
going to explain why this is
fast and scales very well.
You can run it anywhere.
You can run the Endpoints
thing, that API gateway,
you can run it on App Engine.
So if you run on
App Engine, you can
run on App Engine flexible
for whatever you want to do,
or App Engine standard with the
frameworks for Java and Python.
You can run it on
Container Engine.
Compute Engine.
Or really, you can
run it anywhere
where you are able
to run a Container.
If it runs on a
Container, you can run it.
So how does this actually work?
Too much partying yesterday.
My voice is destroyed.
So first what you do
is you deploy an API.
What you do is you
code with GCloud.
You send the API specification,
that openapi.yaml
file that we saw before, and you
send it to the Google Service
Management.
What you're saying here is
you're declaring something new.
And you're going to get
an API name and a version.
Then when you run that
gateway, the gateway
is going to communicate with
the Google Service Management.
And it's going to say,
hey, I want to serve
this API name and this version.
Give me everything I need.
Basically it's going to
get all the information
from the API, plus
authentication, and all
the stuff.
This is just the
deployment part.
That's it.
So that's why you can run that
Container Engine anywhere,
as long as you can--
Container Engine, sorry,
that container for Endpoints.
As long as you're able to use
the Google Service Management
API, which is simply a REST
API, you're able to do this.
And then when you get
a request, no matter
what client is sending it,
rather than going directly
to your code, it goes
first to that container.
The container checks with
the Google Service Control
if this is allowed or not.
If it is allowed, it sends
it to your actual code.
That, again, could
be running anywhere.
And finally it logs everything
to Stackdriver for logs,
and monitoring, and traces.
That's it.
This is the whole thing.
Now, the important
thing is that--
I don't know if
you're able to see it.
I'm not really able to see it--
but there's a little blue box
running both the Extensible
Service Container and my code.
That box is a node.
And I'm calling it a node
because it could be anything.
It could be a path
on kubernetes,
but it could also
be an instance,
an actual node, a
virtual machine,
or it could be anything else.
The whole point is that this
is running together, right?
And the point of
running together
is that since you're
exactly on the same machine,
there's no network
hubs to be added.
So this is very fast.
So it is faster and
scales with your app.
What do I mean by it
scales with your app?
You have one gateway per
container, or per unit
of whatever you're trying
to use as your back-end.
So you could put a
load balancer there,
and the request will go
to the load balancer.
And rather than going directly
from the load balancer
to your code, you're sending
to the Extensible Service Proxy.
And that one will call
the functions, the codes,
as we said before, and then
send it to your back-end.
And this you can
add more and more.
As you can see here, the
Extensible Service Proxy SV
is never the bottleneck, because
it keeps on scaling with you.
So you can imagine how
this scales very well
with kubernetes.
You just create a pod
with two containers.
One container is
your back-end code.
The other container is the
ESP as a sidecar we call it.
So let's do that.
OK.
So the important thing
here is my Go program
will not change at all.
It's going to be
exactly the same code.
So I then need to change it.
I'm going to kill the server.
What I'm going to do is, I'm
going to go to my zero, one.
I have my openapi.yaml.
Openapi.yaml is exactly
what I showed you before,
expressing all the methods for
every path, the definitions, et
cetera.
So you have the echoMessage,
the errorMessage, and that's it.
There's no security here yet.
So what I'm going to
do is, gcloud service
managament deploy openapi.yaml.
Wow, my computer
is not the fastest.
There you go.
So now what we're doing here
is, as I said before, we're
actually talking to--
GCloud is talking--
oh, permission denied.
Oh, I'm in the wrong account.
gcloud auth list, endpoint rock.
That one, gcloud
config set project.
Let me make sure that
is the good one, cloud--
cloud-next-endpoints.
Cloud-next-endpoints.
OK.
Try it again.
OK, cool.
So now what this is doing
is sending that openapi.yaml
to Google Service Manager.
And it's going to
deploy that information.
It's going to analyze it.
So you're going to see
a warning there saying,
hey, the POST in echo
is not protected at all.
Anyone can do whatever
they want with this.
Are you sure?
For now, yes, I am pretty sure
that is what I want to do.
But the whole point is
that now it is deployed.
We're ready to continue.
There's two pieces
of information
that we care about in here.
We get this version
here, the API version.
And also we get the echo
api.endpoints.cloud next
endpoints.cloud.goog.
That is the your API name, your
API ID, which is unique to you.
You can see it's
unique because--
cloud.goog is not unique,
but this is the project name.
Cloud-next-endpoints
is your project name.
So no one else other than
you has access to this.
Cool.
So now what I'm going to
do is I'm going to edit
my container-engine.yaml.
So container-engine.yaml,
what we have is here.
We can see there's
two containers.
There's the
container down there.
It's the echo container,
which is the important one,
it is our business code.
And it's simply a container
in Google Container Registry
that I purchased previously,
because the Wi-Fi is not
the greatest.
But it's already there.
And then we have the container
on top, which is ESP.
And on ESP you can see that
we have a couple parameters.
One of the parameters is
what port this is serving,
8081, which means that
a load balancer will be
sending traffic to that port.
It has the traffic where it
should be sending these back.
So where is your
back-end, which is
localhost 8080, which is where
my echo server is running.
And then we have the
name and the version.
So I'm going to
change the version.
I'm going to update that.
I'm going to set the new one.
And now everything I need
to do is redeploy my server.
So to do that,
simply I do kubectl
apply -f container-engine.
So now what I did is I
updated this version.
So now my new servers
are running here.
We can go check that out.
Oh, that is already running.
So we can go directly
to localhost8001/ui.
We should be able to see
that there's a deployment.
But if we go to paths,
there's one single path
running with two containers.
That has now those two
containers that we decided.
If we want to add
a little bit more,
we can say
container-engine.yaml.
The replica should
be, let's say, three.
I reapply.
And quite fast we should be
able to see that now there's
three paths.
Every single one of those
paths has one container
running my back-end,
one container
running the Endpoint proxy.
Cool.
So let's try this again.
Let's make sure that I'm still
running on the same service.
This the external
IP that I'm going
to be using, which I
don't think changed.
Let me see.
No it did not change.
So now I can send a message,
and you see that it works.
It is amazing.
We did not do anything.
But if you do things
that are not correct,
you're going to see that this is
actually a little bit different
now.
So if you send a path
that is not accepted,
this path, this request,
never got to my back-end.
Instead it's the
ESP container saying
that that was not allowed
because the method does not
exist.
Same here.
If you send something
that doesn't work,
it doesn't work either.
Now, another benefit
that I forgot to mention
before is the fact that--
OK, so now you have
Endpoints, you have Swagger.
You're able to have
all this documentation.
But there's actually
more than that.
You're now also able to--
go away.
No.
It doesn't want to go away.
There you go.
You can't create--
generate code.
And there's a bunch of
options that you can generate.
The cool thing about
this is that, yes,
I can now use your REST API.
Yes, there's now
some limitations
that have been added.
There's logging and
all that stuff running.
But there's also the fact that
if I want to generate, let's
say, PHP.
Why not?
I can come here, open my PHP
code, and the library, model.
It created the echoMessage.
And I'm going to
show much code just
to give you an idea that this
was all to generate directly.
So now you have the capacity of
generating customer libraries
for all the languages
that Swagger supports,
which is actually many of them.
There's actually not that many
languages that people really
use in production that are not
supported by Swagger by now.
OK.
So now if we go back
to my console here--
that one is-- we
have our Endpoints.
So many of them now.
I remember two years ago
there was nothing there.
And we have Cloud Next
Endpoints-- this one here.
So that one was added now
because I deployed this, right?
So if I send requests--
let's send a bunch of
requests with this.
A request that works maybe.
So this is my load testing.
[LAUGHTER]
There you go.
It's like Candy
Crush but with HTTP.
OK.
So now you can see that
I got to an amazing 0.05
requests per second,
which is pretty sad.
But you can see how the
monitoring went up directly,
right?
I did not have to do anything.
Now I have monitoring.
I am able to see what's
going on with that measure.
I'm able to start
to create alerts.
I'm able to say-- normally,
I have around one request
per second.
If I don't have any requests
per second for a little bit,
something's wrong.
You're able to alert
your developers
about these kind
of things, which
is pretty amazing because
it's simply Stackdriver.
You can also go here and see
a little bit more information
about the logs.
What are the requests
you actually received?
And you can see there's
all this information.
There's not much.
But you can actually see
that for every single log
what is the status
code that was returned
and who rejected it, basically.
OK.
So as we said before,
this is amazing.
Now everyone can use my service.
But that's maybe not
what I want to do.
I don't want everyone,
everyone in the world,
to be able to use my service.
For an echo server I'm
pretty confident we're fine.
But if you're doing something
that involves actually
requests that are
expensive, for instance,
you might want to secure this.
So how do we add authentication?
We have monitoring, tracing,
how do we add authentication?
Let's go back there.
Let's talk about
authentication now.
There's four methods that are
supported by Cloud Endpoints.
There's Firebase,
Auth0, there's API keys,
and there's JSON Web Tokens--
also known as JWT, I've
heard, which is crazy.
So what I'm going
to be demoing today
is API keys only, because I
think it's pretty interesting.
If you're a developer
and you have
an API that you're exposing,
think about how hard would it
be to implement this safely.
To implement something
that anyone in the world
can say, create a new API
key, just for themselves,
and start using it, and make
sure that no one else has
access to it, no one else--
and that you're able to
successfully identify
who is using what.
So this is actually incredibly
simple on the Swagger
point of view.
In Swagger, everything
you're going to say
is-- you're going to create
that security definition that
says, API key.
And you say, the
type is API key,
and it's the parameter that's
going to be in the query.
So basically, question mark
key equals that API key.
That's what you're
specifying there.
And then you're saying that
the POST method on echo
is protected by API key.
That's it.
That's everything
you need to do.
So let's do that.
So here I should
have my openapi.yaml.
Oops, 02.
Openapi.yaml.
Here on openapi.yaml it
just added these lines
at the end, security
definitions saying
there's an API key
that is in the query.
And then I said that
I'm requiring API keys
for POST on echo.
So I'm going to do gcloud
service-management deploy
openapi.yaml.
And this is what
it's going to do.
It's going to redeploy
it again, same thing.
And now does that
mean that I'm actually
squashing the previous
version and all of a sudden I
just migrated everyone
to the new version?
No.
That'd be pretty awful.
Because it would
mean that you're not
able to do any tests, basically.
What is going to happen is it's
going to give us a new version.
And that version, no
one is using it yet.
We're going to
need to then update
our kubernetes
cluster, or App Engine,
or whatever you're using
to use that new version.
And then there you can do
rolling updates or whatever
you'd normally do to make sure
that your new version doesn't
break prod.
So we've got our new
version right here.
So I'm going to change my
container yaml, go to v--
I forgot this one here.
Whoa.
Vim is fun sometimes.
Cool.
That looks good.
OK.
So I just changed that.
And then kubectl apply.
Now this changed the service.
Now the new ESP container is
actually using the new version.
So if we go back here
and try to send a message
that should not work.
That's it.
Now it's-- we have API security,
API keys that is exposed here.
Method doesn't allow
unregistered callers.
Please use API key or the
form of API consumer identity
to call this API.
Who wrote that?
Not me.
Yeah.
This is super simple to use.
And it's now secured.
My Go code has not changed yet.
So how do we make this work?
I want to call that API.
So the way it's going to
work is I need to go to here.
And I'm going to
create an API manager.
I'm going to go to credentials.
We're going to
create a new API key.
We're going to copy here.
Go back and say,
key equals that.
I'm going to send it.
And now it works.
And this is pretty
cool, because it
means that anyone can go
and create a new API key
and start using it
and be identified.
So make sure--
I'm not following the
script at all anymore.
And for the demos I want to make
sure I don't forget anything
that I want to tell you.
Cool.
So, yeah.
This now works.
Our next step is, OK,
so API keys are cool,
but are they actually safe?
There's a very good
document written on this,
on documentation that we
published not that long ago.
And you can read it.
But the interesting thing
about it is that they are not,
basically.
An API key has a big problem,
which is you sending it
with every single request.
So you're sending an API
key over HTTP in a URL.
That's going to get
logged somewhere.
Everyone's going to find it.
You're out of luck.
You could also put it in
your HTML if you want to.
And now everyone
can have it too.
So it is not super safe.
But when you're
doing authentication
across different projects, like
a client that has an API key.
This is super simple
and very simple to use.
You don't need to go
overkill with OAuth 2
if you actually trust
what you're doing.
If you have the binary
running somewhere,
it can use an API
key quite safely.
But for other cases,
what do we do?
Well, so as we said,
there's the API key
that you can use with
the API producer,
the API producer
being my echo server.
But also, if you have a
user that wants to use this,
very often what you're
going to have is
the end user is going to use
some kind of authentication.
It's going to obtain an
authentication token.
And they're going to send
that authentication token
to my back-end.
The ESP, the Endpoints--
I never remember
what it stands for,
the S. I think it's extensible,
which doesn't make any sense--
the Endpoints
Extensible Proxy will
take care of that
authentication for you,
too, to verify that
this is actually
sending some authentication.
So for that we can
use Firebase or Auth0.
Also you can use
Jason Web Tokens.
Jason Web Tokens doesn't
require extra steps, actually,
your back-end can generate it.
Firebase and Auth, too, I
think they're very nice.
Because what they
allow you to do
is to have third party
authentication, which
means that you don't need to
care about what authentication
you allow.
It's very easy to
say, I want people
to authenticate with
Google, but also
with Facebook, and Twitter, and
Yahoo, and every other ones.
Your code does not
really change with this.
What you're doing is you're
changing the code on the client
to obtain that token.
That token will be from
a different origin.
But your code in the
back-end will be pretty much
the same, which is pretty nice.
So how do you do it?
In Firebase, you just create a
Firebase security definition.
That's it.
With Auth0, same
thing-- you just
create an Auth0
security definition.
And then you redeploy.
And if you want to know more
about authentication, which
is actually a very interesting
topic, specifically
how to authenticate
different services,
like service-to-service, there's
a session tomorrow from 2:40.
That's what I think, but
that might be changed.
I've heard that schedules
are switching a little bit.
So pay attention to that.
It might be a little
bit later maybe.
And we're going to have two of
the people from the Endpoints
team talking about what are
the best practices to do
authentication across services.
So if you're interested
in that, go check it out,
Service-to-service
Authentication
in Cloud Endpoints.
OK.
Last part, we said
that we're going
to share the API to the world.
We have not shared that yet.
The only person that is allowed
to use it is anyone that has
access to my project, my
Cloud Endpoints Next project,
that project ID on my personal--
well, not personal account--
on my Go account, which
is not good enough.
I want to expose
that API to anyone.
How do I do that?
Well, there's a couple
of ways of doing it.
One of the ways--
I'll get to the
message in a minute.
I thought I had a slide there.
One of the ways is by email.
I can say, this person with
this email is allowed to use it.
So now what you can do is any
project where that email is
authorized to use it, they
are able to enable that API.
So that is a way of
doing it, by email.
You can also do it by Google
Mail Groups, so Google Groups.
You can create a
Google Group and say,
any address that is in that
Google Group, any project that
is part of that address that
is part of the Google Group
will have access to this API.
So you can do--
you can start doing this quite
simply, sharing with only
the people that you care about.
So how do we do that?
So what I'm going to
be doing is I'm going
to have two different accounts.
I have my @golang.org
account, and I also
have my Gmail account.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to share that API with myself,
because I'm very generous.
And then I'm going to
enable it and call it
with an API key
that is generated
from my personal account.
OK.
So first step, we're going
to go here to our Endpoints
right there.
This is the one.
We're going to
click on share API.
And I'm going to just--
OK, I'm going to remove it.
I'm going to share
it with myself.
So I'm going to share it
with campoy83@gmail.com.
Now you know how old I am.
And now I have shared that API.
What's next?
I'm going to log in with
my personal account, which
if I'm not completely
mistaken is here.
OK.
That is my personal account.
You can see it's a
completely different picture.
That's the proof.
And now what I can see is
I can go to API manager.
It's one more API,
nothing crazy here.
You enable the same way
you enabled a Compute
API, you enable any other API.
I'm going to click
on enable API.
And then you have that
Private APIs right there,
which I'm very
thankful it's working.
And here you can see
echo-api.endpoints--
oh, this one here-- echo
api.endpoints.cloud next
endpoints.cloud.goog, which
is the name of the API
that we had.
You click there.
You're going to see
documentation a little bit.
You can enable it.
And when you enable
it, it says, would you
like to create credentials?
Which you should,
because otherwise you
will not be able to call it.
So now I can create--
let's say, other API.
What?
OK.
Let me do it again.
Create an API key.
I'm going to get that one.
And now if I'm here, let's try--
with some API key that is not
allowed, it does not work.
With API key that is
allowed that I created--
I copy/pasted wrongly I think.
Copy.
That is the same.
No.
I did something wrong.
OK.
What I'm going to do is
I'm going to fake it.
So I'm going to go here.
I'm going to go
to my credentials.
Credentials, my API key.
I'm going to put it there.
And you can imagine that that
is actually a different one,
and that this actually worked.
Boom.
Done.
Yeah.
OK.
So the whole idea--
I'm sure I missed some
steps in the demo--
but the whole idea is that
the API key creation now
is not controlled by me.
It's controlled by Google.
But I do decide who
has access to what.
And also, when those calls are
done, now they are monitored.
And you're actually logging
who is accessing what.
And if you want to
remove that access you
can easily do it
by revoking the--
I'm sharing that
API with someone.
So all of a sudden you have
all of this functionality.
And my code is still the same,
which that makes me happy.
So what else can you do
with Cloud Endpoints?
There's actually lots
of really cool stuff.
If you have never used gRPC--
I love gRPC.
I think it's way
better than the REST.
But it's the little problem
that gRPC's amazing.
It's way better than REST.
But people love REST.
So you need to expose
REST APIs, right?
There's a really cool thing
called the gRPC gateway.
And gRPC gateway is a project
that is pretty popular now.
What it does is you give
it a gRPC specification.
And from there it
generates a REST API,
which means that you can
have both at the same time
without writing the
documentation or anything
twice.
This is pretty amazing.
And this is actually
something very similar to what
we do internally at Google.
If you see Google
APIs very often
come in two flavors--
gRPC and REST.
What they do is
pretty much the same.
We generate the gRPC.
We write gRPC.
The gRPC is the fast one.
It's the amazing one.
And REST is the one that
is there for convenience
and very often is fast enough.
But if you're doing things
like Bigtable, Spanner, things
like that, the fact
that you're using JSON
and you're encoding,
decoding that JSON,
it's expensive enough
that you might consider
going to gRPC directly.
And then that logo--
Cloud Functions.
We're working on that.
There's a lot of people asking
for this, Cloud Functions.
I think it was announced
today that they're now beta.
I'm almost sure.
And if not, I just
announced something for you.
I'm almost sure
it was announced.
But it's now beta, so
you can go play with it.
And Cloud Endpoints
for Cloud Functions
will be there at some point.
So we're working on it.
And I'm very excited about
this, because the experience
of having serverless
plus not having
to write any code
for authentication,
logging, or monitoring,
is going to be amazing.
And with that I'm going
to finish because there's
much, much more to learn.
The cool thing is that
we're just starting.
Cloud Endpoints is
a very new project.
And we have basically shown
what our idea is, what
is the core technology of this.
But we are far from done.
We are going to be adding
more and more features.
So if you have features
in mind, let us know.
We're always looking for--
as I said at the beginning,
I'm a Developer Advocate.
My goal is to make
developers happy.
So if you have an idea on
how I could make you happy.
Let me know.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]